when we think of extremely powerful
entities and the gods of Greek mythology
there has to be some kind of order and
system of justice otherwise we
essentially fall into chaos that form of
divine law and order comes from the
Titan goddess known as thermos another
one of the first generation of titans
born from Uranus and Gaia thermoses name
itself was thought to mean order and
many considered her to be the
personification of divine law she was
also seen as a goddess of prophecy a
governing figure to all of the most
ancient Oracle's including the Oracle of
Delphi this power of prophecy certainly
aided the thermos when she created the
traditional rules of conduct which were
to be followed by every god it was also
her divine voice that appeared to
mankind and first introduced them to the
idea of justice and morality helping
them form their first set of primal laws
amongst these rules were the ideas of
hospitality good governance the conduct
of assembly and the pious offering to
the gods thermoses overall role in the
Greek pantheon seemed to be as the voice
of reason and justice being a goddess of
wisdom she naturally made very good
counsel even earning her the nickname
the Lady of Good Counsel she often acted
as the interpreter for God's will a role
she maintained far past the role of the
Titans
unknown to many thermus was actually one
of Zeus's first ever wives and she acted
as his first counselor often been seen
beside his throne advising him on the
precepts of divine law and the rules of
faith together Zeus infamous had many
children the most noticeable being the
Hotez and the mir is the Hirai in the
mirai as you may know them the goddesses
of the seasons and natural order and the
three goddesses of fate and destiny it's
because of her children that thermos had
a strong connection of the goddess
Demeter the horizon represented spring
were thought to bring life and the
Moriah were thought to bring death
almost reflecting the aspects of Demeter
zone daughter Persephone who also
represented life and death being a
goddess of spring as well as the
underworld as I'm sure many of you would
have guessed by now famous sided with
the Olympians sure in the war and when
the war ended she took residence upon
Olympus where she would maintain order
and establish use his authority there is
some mention of thermos in Hesiod's
Theogony
describes the daughter of Zeus and
thermos Vicky has been temporal justice
meaning that she would work alongside
her mother but she was responsible for
the physical execution of the law
sentences and punishments fell to the
key who would carry out the will of her
mother in the Moriah there is a clear
contrast between famous and her daughter
thermos was responsible for the concepts
of morality and justice creating laws to
govern by whereas the key was the
physical embodiment of divine will
carrying out sentences and punishments
as justice demanded the classical
depictions of thermus were thought to be
that of a woman holding a pair of scales
in one hand and a sword in the other the
skills themselves were thought to
represent thermoses ability to determine
whether someone should be punished for
their crime an image that we also see in
Egyptian mythology with Anubis in the
underworld way in the heart of the
deceased against the feather of my heart
the sword she carried or sought to
represent thermoses ability to cut fact
from fiction there was no middle ground
you were either lying or telling the
truth and regardless of which it was
famous could not be fooled thermoses sin
was thought to be a tripod as she was
often depicted as sitting on a
three-legged stool now we can dig a tad
deeper here to try and understand the
association between the two tripods are
often used to support weight and
maintain a stability of an object
particularly from downward and
horizontal forces now this may be
somewhat of a stretch but perhaps we can
see that downward force has been the
gods from above and thermus herself
through law and order providing the
world of stability and means to ensure
that the force of the Gods does not
destroy everything that had been created
now I can be completely wrong here and
perhaps thermister just found three
legged stores particularly comfortable
but it does raise an interesting point
of discussion you may see some modern
depictions very similar to thermos but
instead the woman is blindfolded now
these images are often considered to be
either modern-day versions of thermos or
Lady Justice a figure that embodies many
of the deities surrounding divine order
the blindfold represents impartiality
the idea that justice should be applied
to everyone regardless of wealth power
or status it's quite easy to confuse
thermos with nemesis the goddess of
wrathful retribution but thermos was in
no way wrathful she was pragmatic
extremely rational and she never allowed
her emotions to influence her decision
a thermos or an extremely respected
goddess not only by the ancient Greeks
but in the Greek pantheon itself her
presence almost demanded respect quite
often being referred to by the Greek
gods themselves as lady thermos
there are many wise gods and goddesses
are featuring Greek mythology the
thermos was arguably the wisest of them
all creating a system that stopped the
world from plunging into chaos you can
argue that some of the gods didn't
always follow these rules but for the
most part they were adhered to knowing
that regardless of who they were thermos
would not grant any of the gods immunity
or bias in their punishment if the image
of thermos is one that I'm quite fond of
because she represents the pursuit of
truth and the notion of impartiality
which justice demands but a loved a what
you guys think
do you like thermos in a pragmatic
approach towards justice
or do you prefer the physical and
literal form of Justice that her
daughter takes perhaps you even prefer
nemesis in her approach of retribution
let me know in the comments below so for
those of you wondering about the medusa
statue giveaway i do apologize for the
delay in announcing the winners but
statute king' have been kind enough to
allow me to pick two winners so congrats
to Crystal Sims and Zachary Holmes your
statues have been shipped out to you
guys statue King have also been kind
enough to sponsor this video and for
those of you guys who don't know there
are website that sell really cool
statues with a large selection of
mythology based ones to relate back to
today's video they even have a statue of
Flemish herself and I'm quite happy to
tell you guys that if you use the code
mythology explained or one word you'll
save yourself 10% of any mythology based
statue and shipping to the US is
completely free if that sounds like
something you're interested in then feel
free to head over the statue of King
Kong I'll leave a link in description in
the comments for you guys to use if you
do purchase a statue - feel free to
tweet me a picture of it I'd love to see
which ones you guys choose I hope you
guys enjoyed today's video I'd like to
thank all of you who stuck around
towards the end we are insanely close to
a hundred thousand subscribers and I
want to thank everyone for the support
it's been amazing as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained